there's nothing the media won't repeat
nodding mindlessly when is it other
things CNN Democrats in the rest of
Washington agree on the Ukraine
whistleblower is a hero a brave hero
doing a vital service to this country
he's a whistleblower the funny thing is
and if you live in Washington he knows
we have whistleblowers here and they're
almost always ignored and mistreated by
the people in power all the cool kids
look down on real whistleblowers it's
amazing
most of them you don't even know exists
you never hear their names one exception
to the rule is John Carriacou who is a
CIA whistleblower he blew the whistle on
the agency's covert torture programs and
was profoundly punished for it so we
thought we'd have him on tonight to
assess this new whistleblower job thanks
so much for coming on
my pleasure thing how do you assess this
whistleblower who everyone loved I don't
think this is a whistleblower not at all
I think this is an anonymous source for
the the Democratic staff in the House of
Representatives so that sounds very
different from a whistleblower what is
it whistleblower how is a whistleblower
distinct from whoever this person is a
whistleblower is someone who brings to
light any evidence of waste fraud abuse
illegality or threats to the public
health or public safety and they do this
almost always with a with a great
personal cost attached yes now this is
this so-called whistleblower at the CIA
is someone who is acting anonymously and
remember this person is not an
undercover CIA operative by all accounts
this is an analyst who is not undercover
well you can't hide this person's name
identity just to save him from
embarrassment or or trouble of being
recognized or something like that it's
just not appropriate if this is a
whistleblower he needs to come forward
in public testify an open session and
blow that whistle what's interesting is
that he comes out and makes these
allegations and then the White House
immediately releases the transcript
right so it's kind of end of story in
your case you made allegations that were
true it turned out yes and used to
to prison for saying it oh I did I went
to prison for 23 months and and you know
the same people that that attacked me
are attacking the president robert
muller set up the John Kiriakou task
force at the FBI John Brennan petitioned
Attorney General Holder to charge me
with five felonies including three
counts of espionage all of which were
dismissed and ironically it was Peter
struck who put the cuffs on me in 2012
wait a second so you told you told the
truth about what a federal agency was
doing without the knowledge or consent
of Congress so it's right outside the
democratic channels yes right
undermining democracy they would say now
and MSNBC and Cena did not come to your
defense actually only Fox came to my
defense you know that's something you
and I have never talked about but know
this yeah MSNBC never called me a
whistleblower they called me CIA leaker
John Kiriakou and then CNN after a year
pending trial going through the whole
case after a year they decided to call
me a whistleblower it's tough being a
whistleblower you know political lines
are drawn and that's really where these
things usually turn we're seeing the
Democrats trying to do the same thing
right now with this CIA officer they're
telling us they're imposing upon us
their notion that this person is a
whistleblower and he simply is not I
don't think there's any chance this
person is gonna do almost two years in
prison not a chance you know even his
attorney Mark Zaid is one of these CIA
insiders he's attached at the hip with
the CIA's represented dozens of CIA
people he has a CIA security clearance
if if you are represented by Mark Zaid
and you're claiming to be a
whistleblower you are not you're one of
the only people I can think of who could
give us this perspective on the
whistleblower story and I'm really
ungrateful it's my pleasure thanks for
having a huge up